This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Millions of tweets are posted every day. Most of them get little attention, but there is one user whose tweets always make news. Ding, ding, ding, there's been a photos tweet. The president is up and tweeting this morning. Just tweeted two minutes ago, this, he said, I'm extremely pleased to see that CNN
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦丹塔。每天都有数百万条推文发布。其中大多数受到的关注很少，但有一个用户的推文总是能成为新闻。叮，叮，叮，有一条关于照片的推文。总统今天早上起床发推了。就在两分钟前发了这条推文，他说，我非常高兴地看到，CNN
has finally been exposed as fake news and garbage journalism. It's about time. Trump tweeted quote, The United States has foolishly given Pakistan more than $33 billion in aid over the last 15 years, and they have given us nothing but lies and to see thinking of our leaders. This is not an episode about Donald Trump. It's an episode about an emotion that predates him, but that he has taken to an extreme. We now hear this emotion in the way we talk about a broad range of topics. The emotion is outrage.
终于被揭露为假新闻和垃圾新闻。是时候了。特朗普发推引用道，在过去的15年里，美国愚蠢地向巴基斯坦提供了总计超过330亿美元的援助，而他们给我们的除了谎言和对我们领导人的欺骗，什么也没有。这不是一集关于唐纳德·特朗普的节目。这是一集关于一种比他更古老、但他却将其推向极端的情绪的节目。我们现在在讨论广泛话题的方式中都能听到这种情绪。这种情绪就是愤怒。
With the stench of blatant bias and hurt to stick around, it's embarrassing. It's humiliating to my American and allow us to do something that is not something that people have started. That's not something that people have started. These psychotic Democrats are going to let you president to media mind. Sad, we're towards what will happen to me. I'm a seller. You are a seller.
带着公然偏见的恶臭，而且挥之不去，这太尴尬了。这对我这个美国人来说是一种羞辱，并让我们做一些……这不是人们开始做的事情。这不是人们开始做的事情。这些精神错乱的民主党人将让你把总统交给媒体控制。真悲哀，我们正走向将要发生在我身上的事。我是个卖家。你是个卖家。
Just like the president, many Americans have come to believe that the only way to support change is by jinnying up anger. It isn't enough to say your opponents are wrong, you have to say they are reprehensible. This can be for big issues like immigration and healthcare, it can be for smaller issues, like the new album by Taylor Swift or the popularity of pumpkin spice. Is all this outrage effective? Well, yes. For every moral, emotional word that people use in a tweet, we found that it increased the rate of retweeting
就像总统一样，许多美国人开始相信，支持变革的唯一方法就是挑起愤怒。仅仅说你的对手错了是不够的，你还得说他们十恶不赦。这可能是针对移民和医疗保健这样的大问题，也可能是针对泰勒·斯威夫特的新专辑或南瓜香料的流行这样的小问题。所有这些愤怒有用吗？嗯，是的。我们发现，在推文中，人们使用的每一个带有道德和情感色彩的词，都会使看到它的其他人
from other people who saw it by 15 to 20%. But it comes at a cost. Outrage now leaps from our social media feeds and television screens to PTA meetings and family reunions. Many people feel overwhelmed by the shouting and disengage. Others are so consumed with fury that they become. I just need to get on your lap. I just need to get on your lap. Saturday, January 19th, 2019. Julie Zimmerman checked Twitter and saw something that made her upset. It was a video filmed hundreds of miles from her home in Ohio at the National Mall in Washington DC.
转发推文的比例增加15%到20%。但这是有代价的。愤怒现在从我们的社交媒体动态和电视屏幕跃升至家长教师联合会会议和家庭聚会。许多人感到被呐喊声压得喘不过气来，从而选择退缩。另一些人则被狂怒吞噬，以至于他们变得……我只需要坐在你腿上。我只需要坐在你腿上。2019年1月19日，星期六。朱莉·齐默尔曼查看推特，看到了一些让她心烦意乱的事情。那是一段在距她位于俄亥俄州的家数百英里外的华盛顿特区国家广场拍摄的视频。
There was this old or native American man and these kids surrounded him and were yelling things at him and laughing at him. And as they were blocking his path he apparently was trying to walk over to the link of a memorial or something like that and they wouldn't let them through. The kids surrounding this man look like 15-year-old boys. They were nearly all white. A few were making gestures that look like Tomahawk chops. Some wore hats that red. Make America great again. These kids were making fun of this guy
那里有一个年老的美国原住民男子，这群孩子围着他，对他大喊大叫并嘲笑他。当他们挡住他的去路时，他显然正试图走到纪念馆的连接处或类似的地方，而他们不让他通过。围着这个男子的孩子看起来像是15岁的男孩。他们几乎全是白人。有几个人做出了看起来像战斧劈砍的手势。有些人戴着红色的帽子。让美国再次伟大。这些家伙在取笑这个人
because he was Native American because he had a drum and was chanting something unfamiliar to them. It was pretty cringe worthy. We're going to look at Julie's encounter with a story in some detail because it's revealing about how outrage works today. Like many others watching that day,
因为他是美国原住民，因为他拿着鼓并且在吟唱一些他们不熟悉的歌词。这实在是让人尴尬得脚趾抠地。我们将详细审视朱莉与这个故事的遭遇，因为它揭示了当天的愤怒是如何运作的。就像那天观看视频的许多其他人一样，
Julie fixated on one boy in the video. He was standing directly in front of the Native American man, staring at him. He had what looked like a smirk on his face as the older man sang. His image evoked all the horrifying things Americans have done to Native Americans throughout the centuries. As the day went on, more details emerged. The boys were students at Covington Catholic High School in Kentucky just across the river from Cincinnati, where Julie lives. I started seeing tweets that the kids were chanting, build the wall, build that wall. Julie's son was around the same age as the kids in
朱莉把目光锁定在视频中的一个男孩身上。他正对着美国原住民男子站着，盯着他看。当这位老人唱歌时，他脸上带着一种看起来像是假笑的表情。他的形象让人想起几个世纪以来美国人对美国原住民做过的所有可怕的事情。随着时间的推移，更多的细节浮出水面。这些男孩是肯塔基州卡温顿天主教高中的学生，该学校位于辛辛那提河对岸，朱莉就住在辛辛那提。我开始看到推文说这些孩子在喊，筑墙，筑起那堵墙。朱莉的儿子和视频里的孩子们差不多大，他也上天主教学校。朱莉给他发短信说，我说，你知道的，如果我发现你那样表现。我的意思是，我会吓坏的。
the video and he also went to a Catholic school. Julie texted him, I said, you know, if I ever Caught you acting that way. I mean, I'd be horrified. By the evening, now to the outrage over a video showing the story was everywhere. By now, it's likely that you've seen this video. You've probably seen it by now. The viral video sweeping the internet of a mob of mega hat wearing high school students troubling scene many are calling racist played out in Washington yesterday on the steps of the Lincoln we leave these boys are not getting a good education
到了晚上，对展现这个故事的视频的愤怒情绪已经无处不在。到现在为止，你很可能已经看过这段视频了。你现在大概已经看过了。这段在互联网上迅速走红的视频，展示了一群戴着MAGA帽的高中生围攻的场景，许多人称之为种族主义事件，昨天在华盛顿林肯纪念堂的台阶上上演，我们认为这些男孩没有接受良好的教育，
because it makes little sense to angrily chant build the wall to a population with literally zero illegal immigrants who were here long before we were. I talked to a friend of mine who lives in New York, a former roommate of mine, and she said her yoga teacher called and said, let's drive to that school and Kentucky in protest. Like that's to that school and Kentucky in protest. Like that's the sort of level of reaction people were having to this. Like this yoga teacher in New York wanted to hop in the car and drive 10 hours to protest in front of the school. While Julie's friends were texting her messages of outrage,
因为对一个实际上零非法移民、且在很久以前就来到这里的人群愤怒地高喊“筑墙”，是毫无意义的。我跟我的一位住在纽约的朋友、我的前室友聊过，她说她的瑜伽老师打电话说，让我们开车去肯塔基的那所学校抗议吧。就像那是一种……去肯塔基那所学校抗议。这就像人们对此类事件的反应级别。就像纽约的这位瑜伽老师想要跳上车，开车10小时去那所学校前抗议一样。当朱莉的朋友们给她发来充满愤怒的信息时，
her son was having very different conversations about the same video. His friends had started texting him at some point on Saturday saying, you know, I think that these guys are getting a bum rap. I don't think they're guilty of what they're being accused of. Sunday, January 20, 2019. In the late morning, after church, Julie checked Twitter. She saw that someone had uploaded a nearly two-hour long video, which showed much more of the confrontation between the Catholic school students and the Native American man. I started watching because I wanted to show my son
她的儿子正在就同一段视频进行完全不同的对话。周六的某个时候，他的朋友们开始给他发短信说，你知道的，我觉得这些家伙受到了不公正的指控。我认为他们并没有犯被指控的罪行。2019年1月20日，星期日。上午晚些时候，礼拜结束后，朱莉查看了推特。她看到有人上传了一段将近两小时的视频，其中展示了天主教学校学生与美国原住民男子之间冲突的更多画面。我开始观看，因为我想给我的儿子看
where the kids had been chanting build the wall. He challenged me on that point, and I watched the Hour Plus video of the incident, and I couldn't find anywhere where they had been chanting that. And that wasn't all. This is what the longer video showed. The kids were on the mall for the annual march for life, which is an anti-abortion march that happens every year in January.
孩子们是在哪里高喊“筑墙”的。他在这一点上反驳了我，我观看了长达一个多小时的事件视频，却找不到任何他们曾经高喊这一口号的地方。不仅如此。这段较长的视频显示了以下内容。孩子们在广场上参加年度“为生命游行”，这是一个每年一月都会举行反堕胎游行。
It was right before Martin Luther King Day. The mall was packed. There was a group called the Blacky-Wroot Israelites. It was right before Martin Luther King Day. The mall was packed. There was a group called the Black Hebrew Israelites and they were yelling vile things at the kids. A bunch of babies made out of insects. Right, tell the pub babies. This is what America makes America great looks like. You know, somebody yelling something out, you doesn't give you justification to yell
当时正值马丁·路德·金纪念日之前。广场挤满了人。有一个名为“黑色希伯来以色列人”的群体。当时正值马丁·路德·金纪念日之前。广场挤满了人。有一个名为“黑色希伯来以色列人”的群体，他们向孩子们大喊恶毒的话语。一群由昆虫做成的婴儿。对，告诉公众婴儿。这就是美国让美国变得伟大的样子。你知道，有人喊出一些话，并不意味着你有理由回喊
anything back, but I thought that set a tone that these kids, some of whom may have never been in a situation like this, might have been feeling nervous or attacked or I don't know it. The insults being yelled by the Black Hebrew Israelites definitely altered my understanding of what happened next. The indigenous people's march was also taking place in DC that day. Nathan Phillips was the older man in the original viral video. I saw Phillips walk over to the kids on this longer video, and remember the original video had just shown Phillips surrounded by these kids,
任何东西，但我认为这定下了基调，这些孩子中有些人可能从未经历过这样的情况，可能会感到紧张或受到攻击，或者我不知道。黑色希伯来以色列人怒吼的侮辱绝对改变了我对接下来发生的事情的理解。原住民游行当天也在华盛顿特区举行。内森·菲利普斯是最初疯传的视频中的那位老人。我在这个较长的视频中看到菲利普斯走向孩子们，请记住，最初的视频只显示菲利普斯被这些孩子包围，
and the extrapolation originally was that these kids had walked up to Phillips and surrounded him and blocked his path and not allowed him to pass. Well, as you watch the longer video, you see Phillips and an entourage. I mean, there were a lot of people with Phillips all walking over to talk to the kids. So, Phillips had not been trying to get somewhere and these kids blocked him. He actually went up and initiated the interaction with the kids. And what were the kids doing? What were they chanting?
最初的推断是这些孩子们走到菲利普斯身边包围了他，挡住了他的去路，不让他通过。嗯，当你观看较长的视频时，你会发现菲利普斯和一群随从。我的意思是，有很多人和菲利普斯一起走过去跟孩子们说话。所以，菲利普斯并不是想去某个地方却被这些孩子们挡住了。实际上是他走过去并主动与孩子们互动。孩子们在做什么？他们在唱什么？
What were they shouting? Some of them were trying to make their friends laugh. Some of them were being offensive. I think doing a Tomahawk chop is an offensive thing to do. And the student who was smarting at Nathan Phillips? He was laughing for a while, and then they kind of locked eyes. And I don't know what he was thinking. I don't know if he was feeling, but I've seen that look on teenagers
他们在喊什么？他们中的一些人试图逗笑他们的朋友。他们中的一些人具有冒犯性。我认为做战斧劈砍手势是一件具冒犯性的事情。而那个在内森·菲利普斯面前假笑的学生呢？他笑了一会儿，然后他们目光相对。我不知道他在想什么。我不知道他当时是什么感受，但我从青少年身上见过那种眼神，
where you've got waves of thoughts passing through your head and your underlying thinking is, what do I do? I don't know what to do. You know, he looked nervous to me. I'm not sure if I'm right or wrong, but I'm not sure if I'm right or wrong. I'm not sure if I'm right or wrong. I'm not sure if I'm right or wrong.
脑海中闪过层层思绪，而你内心深处真正的想法是，我该怎么办？我不知道该怎么做。你知道的，在我看来他显得很紧张。我不知道自己是对还是错，但我不知道自己是对还是错。我不知道自己是对还是错。我不知道自己是对还是错。
Julie had seen the smirking boy as emblematic of the terrible things done to Native Americans. Now, she saw a teenager who was trying hard not to show his friends that he was nervous. On social and broadcast media, the outrage flipped. If you were left leaning, you were outraged by these kids. Originally, if you were conservative, you just put your head under a rock because even you couldn't defend what you originally saw.
朱莉曾将这个假笑的男孩视为对美国原住民所作所为的可怕象征。现在，她看到的是一个极力向朋友掩饰自己紧张的青少年。在社交媒体和广播电视上，愤怒的情绪发生了逆转。如果你是偏左翼的，你最初会对这些孩子们感到愤怒。如果你是保守派，你最初会把头埋在沙子里，因为连你自己都无法为你最初看到的东西辩护。
Then there was a reaction to it where a lot of conservatives after they had seen the longer videos started defending these kids. And what was interesting to me was how difficult it was for people to change their original take on it. I was afraid to tell a few people initially that I had changed my mind about the coming and Catholic thing, which is crazy.
后来出现了一种反应，许多保守派在观看了较长的视频后开始为这些孩子们辩护。让我感兴趣的是，人们改变对这件事最初的看法是多么困难。最初我不敢告诉几个人我改变了对卡温顿天主教事件的看法，这太疯狂了。
Like, why can't you just say, you know, I think it was wrong about this, but I knew some people would be upset because it's as though you're giving your enemy ammunition by admitting that they might be right and you might have been wrong and you can't ever show weakness or admit that maybe the other side has a point. Julie told a friend about her change of heart, and her friend encouraged her to write an essay about it. And I wrote that essay probably in 15 minutes. I mean, it just spilled out.
就像，你为什么不能直接说，你知道的，我当时可能弄错了，但我知道有些人会感到不安，因为这就好像你承认他们可能是对的而你可能错了，这就等于在给你的敌人送弹药，你永远不能表现出软弱或承认也许对方有道理。朱莉把她心态的转变告诉了一位朋友，她的朋友鼓励她写一篇关于此事的文章。我大概在15分钟内就写好了那篇文章。我的意思是，它就那么倾泻而出了。
And I submitted it for publication, and it was published very quickly. The essay was published in the Atlantic. The headline read, I failed the Covington Catholic Test. In the piece, Julie admitted she had been hasty and quick to judgment. Almost immediately after her essay was posted, it prompted howls of outrage from the right. My essay was weaponized against liberals, against progressives. And I, you know, it made me uncomfortable to see that. Like, oh gosh, did I make a mistake here?
然后我把它提交发表，它很快就发表了。这篇文章发表在《大西洋月刊》上。标题是，我没通过卡温顿天主教测试。在这篇文章中，朱莉承认自己当时过于草率，急于下结论。她的文章发布后几乎立刻招来了右翼的愤怒咆哮。我的文章被武器化了，用来反对自由派，反对进步派。而我，你知道的，看到这些让我感到不舒服。就像，噢天哪，我在这里犯了错误吗？
My brother-in-law called my husband to say, Rush Limbaugh just mentioned your wife's name on the air. And I thought, oh gosh, what have I done? One of the drive-by media outlets that really roasted these kids from Covington was at the Atlantic. And a writer at the Atlantic has published a piece, I failed the Covington Catholic test. Next time there's a viral story, I'll wait for more facts to emerge. Julie Erwin Zimmerman. She was one of the early pilots on, and she is begging
我姐夫打电话给我丈夫说，拉什·林堡刚刚在节目中提到了你妻子的名字。我想，天哪，我做了什么？那些对这些卡温顿的孩子们大加挞伐的随性媒体 outlets 之一就是《大西洋月刊》。《大西洋月刊》的一位作家发表了一篇文章，我没通过卡温顿天主教测试。下次再有病毒式传播的故事时，我会等待更多事实浮出水面。朱莉·欧文·齐默尔曼。她是早期发表言论的人之一，而她正在乞求
for forgiveness. She failed the test. She went along with what? Why does anybody in their right mind? I know the temptation, but why isn't there even a moment's pause when anything from social media becomes source material in drive-by media? It is a cesspool, and everybody knows that it's a cesspool. Russia Limbaugh was wrong in several ways. Julie didn't work at the Atlantic and had nothing to do with their initial coverage. And she was not an only piter on. Before she wrote her essay, she herself had posted nothing on social media about the comington Catholic students. In addition, lots of journalists had in fact covered the story with nuance. Ironically, Rush Limbaugh was doing exactly what Julie had initially done.
原谅。她没通过测试。她顺应了什么？为什么任何神志正常的人？我知道这种诱惑，但为什么当社交媒体上的任何内容成为随性媒体的素材时，甚至连片刻的停顿都没有？这是一个粪坑，每个人都知道这是个粪坑。拉什·林堡在几个方面都错了。朱莉并没有在《大西洋月刊》工作，也与他们最初的报道没有任何关系。她也不是唯一的发声者。在她写文章之前，她本人并没有在社交媒体上发布任何关于卡温顿天主教学生的言论。此外，实际上有很多记者带着细致入微的视角报道了这个故事。讽刺的是，拉什·林堡所做的正是朱莉最初做的事情。
He was leaping to sweeping conclusions about liberals, about Julie, about journalists, with very limited evidence. This is the way our cycles of outrage work. Each blast produces misstatements, exaggerations, and errors. These are then seized upon by the other side, which proceeds to produce its own misstatements, exaggerations, and errors. The cycle feeds on itself. The outrage in the Covington Catholic Schools' candle is emblematic of our times.
他在证据非常有限的情况下，对自由派、对朱莉、对记者草率地下了宏大的结论。这就是我们的愤怒循环运作的方式。每一次爆发都会产生失实陈述、夸大和错误。这些随后被另一方抓住，进而产生他们自己的失实陈述、夸大和错误。这个循环自我滋养。卡温顿天主教学校事件中的愤怒是我们这个时代的象征。
Right-wing talk radio invented the modern art of the rant. Cable television pundits perfected it. Social media has made outrage part of daily discourse. Now, instead of a handful of screaming voices on radio and TV, you have thousands of people on the right and the left, and raged about politics and each other. Events that would never have been considered news stories now dominate the headlines. Julie used to be a reporter and editorial writer at the Cincinnati Enquara.
右翼脱口秀广播发明了现代诡辩艺术。有线电视名嘴将其臻于完美。社交媒体让愤怒成为日常话语的一部分。现在，广播和电视上不再只有少数几个尖叫的声音，而是成千上万持左右翼观点的人，对政治和彼此感到愤怒。那些本绝不会被视为新闻故事的事件现在占据了头条。朱莉曾是《辛辛那提问讯报》的记者和社论作家。
If you were my editor and I came to you and said, yeah, this Native American guy and these kids and mega hats kind of got in this tense standoff on the mall today. And I think it's a story. Any self-respecting editor would say, you know, did somebody get shot? You know, how is this a story? This weird confrontations between people happen all the time and we don't consider them to be news stories. But the ground rules have changed.
如果你是我的编辑，而我来找你说，嘿，今天这个美国原住民老兄和这群戴着MAGA帽的孩子在广场上陷入了这种激烈的对峙。我觉得这是一个故事。任何一个自尊的编辑都会说，你知道的，有人中枪了吗？你知道的，这怎么能算是一个新闻故事？这种人与人之间奇怪的对峙时有发生，我们并不认为它们是新闻故事。但基本规则已经改变了。
All of a sudden, there are powerful incentives to be fastest to react and loudest to shout. People are falling all over each other to be first in line to say how awful this was. You get to show how woke you are or how conservative you are without actually doing any work. You just look at something, you're retweeted, you try to make a really smart, funny comment
突然之间，人们有了强大的动机去争取最快反应和最大嗓门。人们争先恐后地排在第一位去表达这件事有多么糟糕。你不需要做任何工作就能展示你有多清醒或多保守。你只需要看一眼什么东西，转发它，然后试着发表一个非常聪明、有趣的评论，
that thousands of people will retweet, and then you kind of pat yourself on the back for being involved in the conversation, but you have done nothing. Is Julie right? Is all this anger really accomplishing nothing? What researchers have found about the science of viral outrage when we come back. Cast your mind back to a party, one that happened a long, long time ago. Someone at this party does something bad. Maybe steal something. The group has to decide what to do with this law breaker. Do nothing and the transgressor might do bad stuff again. Better to punish it or cast them out. Over thousands of generations, humans learned
让成千上万的人转发，接着你就可以因为参与了这场对话而自我感觉良好，但你实际上什么也没做。朱莉说得对吗？所有这些愤怒真的什么也没accomplish吗？当我们回归时，研究人员对病毒式愤怒的科学有何发现。把思绪拉回到一个派对，一个很久很久以前发生的派对。派对上的某个人做了一件坏事。也许偷了什么东西。群体必须决定如何处置这个违法者。什么都不做，违规者可能再次作恶。最好惩罚他或将他驱逐。经过数千代的演变，人类了解到
that punishing bad behavior accomplished useful things. It's like evolution placed a bet on that being a good idea for the group. This is Yale psychologist Molly Crocket. Molly says outrage about wrongdoing and the punishments it produced get people in line. This was good for the group. It also happened to be good for individuals. Our brains evolved to give us a little boost when we get outraged and punish someone.
惩罚不良行为能带来有用的结果。这就好像进化押注这对群体来说是个好主意。这是耶鲁大学心理学家莫莉·克罗克特。莫莉说，对不当行为的愤怒以及随之而来的惩罚能让人们守规矩。这对群体有利。它碰巧也对个人有利。我们的大脑进化到在我们感到愤怒并惩罚某人时给我们一点奖励。
When people decide to punish somebody who's behaved unfairly, we see activation in brain areas associated with reward, including the stratum and the medial prefrontal cortex. In layman's terms, calling out another person's bad behavior feels good. Molly and her team have conducted experiments where they ask volunteers to play the role of a punisher. When the volunteer sees something unfair, she can punish the person responsible. Molly says people ask to play the role of punisher, are not only willing to penalize wrongdoers, but to make personal sacrifices in order to do so. For example, in one experiment, the punisher sees that someone has divided a part of money unfairly rather than share it equitably with another person.
当人们决定惩罚一个表现不公的人时，我们会看到与奖励相关的大脑区域被激活，包括纹状体和内侧前额叶皮层。用通俗的话说，指出别人的不良行为感觉很好。莫莉和她的团队进行了实验，他们要求志愿者扮演惩罚者的角色。当志愿者看到不公平的事情时，她可以惩罚责任人。莫莉说，被要求扮演惩罚者角色的志愿者不仅愿意惩罚做错事的人，甚至愿意为此做出个人牺牲。例如，在一个实验中，惩罚者看到有人不公平地分了一笔钱，而不是与另一个人公平分享。
I can spend some money to burn your money. And you get sent a message saying that that happened. And you get a final payoff. And you learn how big it could have been if I hadn't burned some of your money. In this rational model of punishment, wrongdoers know they are being punished. In fact, it is this knowledge that is supposed to act as a deterrent. But Molly and her team asked a deeper question. Would volunteers also be willing to punish transgressors who don't get told they are being punished? The only reason why I would punish you when it's in secret is if I get some personal satisfaction
我可以花一些钱来烧掉你的钱。然后你会收到一条消息，说这件事发生了。你得到了最终的报酬。并且你会知道，如果我没有烧掉你的一些钱，你本可以得到多少。在这种理性的惩罚模型中，做错事的人知道他们正在受到惩罚。事实上，正是这种认知应该起到威慑作用。但莫莉和她的团队提出了一个更深层次的问题。志愿者是否也愿意惩罚那些并不知道自己正在受罚的违规者？我之所以要在暗地里惩罚你的唯一原因，就是因为我知道你这个不公平的人最后得到的钱变少了，从中获得了一些个人满足感。
from knowing that you as an unfair person end up with less money. Even when transgressors had no idea they were being punished, when they didn't know how much they would have received otherwise, Molly found that punishers were more than happy to meet out justice. There's a sort of visceral satisfaction in doling out punishment, and this is corroborated by the brain imaging evidence which shows that when we decide to punish, we see activation and brain areas associated with reward. Outrage in other words has been so valuable in our revolutionary history
即使违规者根本不知道自己正在受罚，当他们不知道自己本来可以得到多少钱时，莫莉发现惩罚者仍然非常乐意伸张正义。实施惩罚有一种本能的满足感，这得到了脑成像证据的支持，该证据表明，当我们决定惩罚时，我们会看到与奖励相关的大脑区域被激活。换句话说，愤怒在我们的进化史中非常有价值，
that it operates like other important biological functions. It gives us pleasure. But here's the thing, remember the context in which outrage evolved. It evolved in an environment where we interacted with people face-to-face in small groups, in situations where we're going to repeatedly interact with the same people. In this context, outrage produced benefits, but it also came with costs that prompted people to be judicious about it. If your neighbor, Ag, stalled someone's food and you vented your anger at him, it might feel good,
以至于它的运作方式与其他重要的生理功能一样。它带给我们快乐。但问题是，记住愤怒进化的背景。它进化于这样一个环境中：我们在小群体中进行面对面的互动，在这些情境中，我们会与同一群人进行重复互动。在这种背景下，愤怒产生了好处，但也伴随着代价，这促使人们对此保持明智和谨慎。如果你的邻居奥格偷了某人的食物，你向他发泄愤怒，这可能会感觉很好，
but it could also be dangerous. Awgh could get mad at you, punch you in the throat. You would have to judge when, and where, and how much it made sense to express outrage. What happens when we take an emotion, carefully calibrate it for small net groups, and give it a global platform? It's not very well equipped for the environment in which we find ourselves now, where the audience is much, much bigger than it traditionally
但也可能是危险的。奥格可能会对你生气，一拳打在你的喉咙上。你必须判断在何时、何地以及在多大程度上表达愤怒是有意义的。当我们把一种为小团体精心校度过的情绪放到一个全球平台上时，会发生什么？它并不太适应我们现在所处的环境，因为受众比传统情况要大得多、多得多。
has been. Now I can be angry at total strangers half a world away and my physical costs of expressing that outrage close to zero. Given that the psychological benefits are high and the physical costs are low, there are a few checks on outrage anymore. This is why many of us today feel surrounded by outrage. It's nearly impossible to escape. This is why many of us today feel surrounded by outrage. It's nearly impossible to escape.
现在，我可以对半个世界之外的完全陌生人生气，而我表达这种愤怒的物理成本几乎为零。鉴于心理收益很高而物理成本很低，对愤怒的制约已经所剩无几。这就是为什么我们今天许多人都感到被愤怒包围。几乎无法逃脱。这就是为什么我们今天许多人都感到被愤怒包围。几乎无法逃脱。
No, what's funny is, you should control it. Thousands and thousands of United States veterans have gone into the United States. You never lived a day in my country. It's absolutely a problem. Are you trying to say that this country does not... Molly has noticed something else. Many of us don't want to escape the vitriol. People on both the right and left revel in it.
不，有趣的是，你应该控制它。成千上万的美国退伍军人加入了美国。你一天都没有在我的国家生活过。这绝对是个问题。你是想说这个国家不……莫莉注意到了另一件事。我们中的许多人并不想逃离这种尖刻的指责。右翼和左翼的人都陶醉其中。
As a user of social media, one thing that I noticed in my own behavior, particularly after the 2016 elections was just how much more time I was spending online and particularly how I felt myself getting sucked into feedback loops where I would read something, I would feel outraged about it, I would feel compelled to share it with my friends, I would then be sort of obsessively checking to see whether people had responded, how they had responded, you know, lather rinse repeat. Every time Molly plugged herself into circuits of outrage, every time she fired off a zinger
作为一个社交媒体用户，我在自己的行为中注意到的一件事，特别是在2016年大选之后，是我花在网上的时间多了多少，尤其是当我感觉到自己被吸入反馈循环时：我会阅读一些东西，对此感到愤怒，忍不住想与朋友分享，然后我会像着迷一样查看别人是否回应了、是如何回应的，你知道的，清洗、冲洗、重复。每当莫莉把自己接入愤怒的电路，每当她对特朗普总统发表一句尖酸刻薄的言论时，
about President Trump, the ancient circuits in her brain gave her a little reward. Fast forward to early 2017. President Donald Trump's executive order barring many foreigners, including all refugees from entering the U.S. caused confusion at airports around the world. Travelers of the United States. The Trump administration began advancing the series of anti-immigration measures. A friend of mine shared an article that the story was about
她大脑中的古老电路就会给她一点奖励。快进到2017年初。唐纳德·特朗普总统禁止许多外国人（包括所有难民）进入美国的行政命令，引发了世界各地机场的混乱。前往美国的旅客。特朗普政府开始推行一系列反移民措施。我的朋友分享了一篇文章，这个故事讲的是
something like the economic benefits of immigrants and how farms in California were seeing tomatoes on the vine because they couldn't find enough workers to harvest those tomatoes. And I read this, I was outraged, I shared it, and then a lot of my friends liked it, and then I got a comment from someone that I didn't even
诸如移民的经济效益之类的事情，以及加州的农场里番茄烂在藤上，因为他们找不到足够的工人来收割这些番茄。我读了这篇文章，我感到很愤怒，我分享了它，然后我的很多朋友都点赞了，接着我收到了一个我甚至并不是
really know that well. And they said the date of this article is 2011. 2011. The president at that time was not Donald Trump, but someone Molly admired. Barack Obama. Molly quietly deleted the Facebook post, but the incident was a wake-up call. She looked back on her behavior, how she would get lost in a world of posts, shares, and likes.
真的很熟悉的人的评论。他们说这篇文章的日期是2011年。2011年。当时的总统不是唐纳德·特朗普，而是莫莉崇拜的人。贝拉克·奥巴马。莫莉默默地删除了这条Facebook动态，但这次事件是一个警钟。她回顾了自己的行为，反思自己是如何迷失在帖子、分享和点赞的世界中的。
It was like coming out of a trance and having this realization that time had disappeared and that I had been engaged in a feedback loop, not unlike the apparatus that my PhD lab used to train rats to press leavers to get cocaine. Literally, I'm not saying that social media is cocaine, I think they're actually really important distinctions between substance addiction and social media use and they get conflated a lot in the media.
这就像是从一场 trance（恍惚）中醒来，意识到时间已经消失了，而自己一直卷入一个反馈循环中，这与我的博士实验室用来训练老鼠按压杠杆以获得可卡因的装置没什么两样。真的，我并不是说社交媒体就是可卡因，我认为物质成瘾和社交媒体使用之间其实有着非常重要的区别，它们在媒体中经常被混为一谈。
But one thread that they have in common is that both of these processes do seem to tap into our reinforcement learning circuitry in the brain. Most of us underestimate how powerful this brain circuitry can be, how vulnerable we are to the psychological rewards that come from feeling really, truly mad about something, and then seeing our outrage amplified by others. Social rewards are just as powerful, if not more powerful in driving learning and decision-making,
但它们的一个共同点是，这两种过程似乎都利用了我们大脑中的强化学习回路。我们大多数人低估了这种大脑回路的力量，低估了我们对以下心理奖励的脆弱性：因某事感到真正、彻底的愤怒，然后看到我们的愤怒被他人放大。社交奖励在推动学习和决策方面，
then chocolate or money, right? The approval of our peers is like the most potent reward you can get for social beings like us. Social media platforms take our love for this kind of approval and poor rocket fuel on it. When you share the story with a group of friends in the days before social media, you might not know exactly what they thought of it. You had to watch their faces, and even then, the responses might be ambiguous. But these days?
即使不比巧克力或金钱更强大，也同样强大，对吧？对于像我们这样的社交生物来说，同龄人的认可可以说是你能得到的最高效的奖励。社交媒体平台承载了我们对这种认可的喜爱，并为其注入了火箭燃料。在社交媒体出现之前的日子里，当你与一群朋友分享一个故事时，你可能并不确切知道他们是怎么想的。你不得不观察他们的脸，即便如此，他们的反应也可能是模棱两可的。但现在呢？
Now we get a count. We can see, oh, 10 friends liked that article I shared. But the one I shared yesterday got 70 likes. So these are signals that we can use to tune our behavior and we have quantified social feedback now in a way that was much more vague before social media. Since humans are smart animals who learn quickly from feedback, we discover that there are very specific ways to get this delicious social approval.
现在我们有了计数。我们可以看到，哦，有10个朋友喜欢我分享的那篇文章。但我昨天分享的那篇获得了70个点赞。所以这些是我们用来调整行为的信号，现在我们以一种在社交媒体出现之前更为模糊的方式对社交反馈进行了量化。既然人类是从反馈中快速学习的聪明动物，我们就会发现获得这种美妙社交认可的非常具体的方法。
My name is Jay Van Bavill, I'm a psychology professor at New York University. Jane's team have analyzed more than half a million tweets. He has found there is an easy way to dramatically increase likes and retweets. For every moral, emotional word that people use in a tweet, we found that it increased the rate of retweeting from other people who saw it by 15 to 20%. Posts were retweeted 15 to 20% more if people used a moral or emotional word.
我叫杰·范·贝维尔，我是纽约大学的心理学教授。杰的团队分析了超过五十万条推文。他发现有一种简单的方法可以急剧增加点赞数和转发数。我们发现，在推文中，人们使用的每一个道德和情感词汇，都会使看到它的其他人转发推文的比例增加15%到20%。如果人们使用了道德或情感词汇，帖子的转发量会增加15%到20%。
The list of words that J.N.S colleagues defined as moral and emotional is quite long. Curse words are on the list, of course. Some other examples are words like hate, war, greed, punish. J. read me some sample tweets. So on the topic of same-sex marriage, here's an example tweet from a conservative. Gay marriage is a diabolical evil lie aimed at destroying our nation. And the moral emotional words here are evil and destroying, and they're both the negative
杰和他的同事们定义为道德和情感的词汇列表相当长。当然，诅咒词在名单上。其他一些例子包括仇恨、战争、贪婪、惩罚等词汇。杰给我读了一些示例推文。所以在同性婚姻这个话题上，这里有一个保守派的示例推文。同性婚姻是一个旨在摧毁我们国家的邪恶谎言。这里的道德情感词汇是邪恶和摧毁，它们都是消极的、
highly potent words. From a liberal, we have a tweet, New Mormon policy-bans children of same-sex parents. This church wants to punish children? A question mark. Are you kidding me? Shame. You can also generate outrage without using those specific words, of course. You can say, can you believe she said that? Or, what kind of a country do we live in today?
极具潜力的词汇。来自一个自由派的推文，新的摩门教政策禁止同性恋父母的孩子。这个教会想惩罚儿童？一个问号。你在开玩笑吗？真可耻。当然，你也可以在不使用这些特定词汇的情况下引发愤怒。你可以说，你敢相信她说了那话吗？或者，我们今天生活在一个什么样的国家里？
Jays analysis didn't include tweets like that. But even using his more conservative measure, J found that moral and emotional words caused messages to spread. And you can, you know, jam a lot of words that have moral emotions in them in a single message and increase the likelihood your message is going to be shared by 60 or 80 or 100%. This outrage often begets more outrage. Twitter is weird because, you know, there's a level of outrage,
杰的分析不包括这样的推文。但即便使用他更为保守的测度，杰发现道德和情感词汇确实会让信息传播开来。而且你可以，你知道的，在一条信息中塞进许多带有道德情感的词汇，从而使你的信息被分享的可能性增加60%、80%或100%。这种愤怒往往会引发更多的愤怒。推特很奇怪，因为，你知道的，存在一种愤怒水平，
then you have people who are outraged about the outrage because it's the wrong type of outrage. Then you have people who are outraged about that outrage. And then you have another group of people who are outraged that you're not outraged enough. So you have these four forms of outrage going on at any given time, and it just cycles through issue after issue on a 24 hour basis. To be sure, outrage sometimes produces real change. It can bring together marginalized communities. It can fuel social movements such as the Arab Spring or Black Lives Matter.
然后你会发现有人对这种愤怒感到愤怒，因为这是错误的愤怒类型。然后你会发现有人对那种愤怒感到愤怒。接着还有另一群人对你不够愤怒感到愤怒。所以在任何给定的时间，这四种形式的愤怒都在发生，它只是在24小时内周而复始地在各个议题间循环。可以肯定的是，愤怒有时确实会带来真正的改变。它可以将边缘化群体团结在一起。它可以推动社会运动，如阿拉伯之春或黑人的命也是命。
It can help with elections. It can help with elections. What? What? What? That's right. Outrage can be especially effective if your goal is to pull someone down. After all, this might be what the emotion was designed for in the first place. Today, Al Franken took to the mic as his political career came crashing down.
它对选举有帮助。它对选举有帮助。什么？什么？什么？没错。如果你的目标是把某人拉下马，愤怒尤其有效。毕竟，这可能是这种情绪最初被设计出来的目的。今天，阿尔·弗兰肯走上话筒，随着他的政治生涯崩塌。
I will be resigning as a member of the United States Senate. His resignation came after a number of comments coming from his day. I was wrong. In an apology video posted on Twitter, Kathy Griffin is begging for forgiveness after images of her holding the severed screen news overnight.
我将辞去美国参议员职务。他的辞职是在他当天的许多言论之后发生的。我错了。在推特上发布的道歉视频中，凯西·格里芬在手持被割断的屏幕新闻的图像一夜之间爆红后恳求原谅。
Kevin Hart stepping down as host this came just days after his name was announced and of course, after a firestorm over past anti-gay tweets. Coming up, what outreach does not do well and how to deploy fury more effectively. It can feel good to start a fire. To see all the push notifications that come to your phone as people like and retweet your outrage. Studies show that the more outrage you demonstrate, the more your message is likely to spread. But psychologist William Brady at Yale says there is a great paradox in the way outrage works. Outrage leads to engagement,
凯文·哈特卸任主持人职务，这距离他的名字被宣布仅几天时间，当然，此前还爆发了一场关于过去反同性恋推文的风暴。接下来，愤怒不擅长做什么，以及如何更有效地调动怒火。点燃一把火感觉可能会很好。看到手机上弹出的无数通知，因为人们点赞并转发你的愤怒。研究表明，你表现出的愤怒越多，你的消息传播的可能性就越大。但耶鲁大学的心理学家威廉·布雷迪表示，愤怒的运作方式中存在一个巨大的悖论。愤怒会导致参与，
but not always to change. The type of people you're getting to that is giving you the shares and the likes. It tends to be people who share your political views, so people have the same political ideology. In other words, outrage is very effective at spreading a message within an echo chamber. The use of outrage, the use of moral and emotional language on social media, it really depends on the context in what you're trying to accomplish. If you want to rally the troops, get my people who already agree with me to get interested and to get motivated to act, or is it really to try to persuade others?
但并不总是带来改变。你吸引到的那些给予你分享和点赞的人。往往是那些分享你政治观点的人，也就是具有相同政治意识形态的人。换句话说，愤怒在同温层内传播信息非常有效。愤怒的使用，社交媒体上道德和情感语言的使用， realmente 取决于你试图实现的目标的背景。如果你想凝聚士气，让那些已经同意我观点的人对此感兴趣并有动力采取行动，还是真的试图说服其他人？
If your goal is the former, then expressing yourself with moral emotions like outrage can be really effective. If your goal is the latter, then perhaps it's not the best idea. In a study that William is conducted with J. Van Bevel, he found that tweets without a moral and emotional tone were better able to start conversations between people from different political persuasions. In some ways, this makes intuitive sense. When was the last time you changed your mind because someone screamed at you?
如果你的目标是前者，那么用愤怒等道德情感来表达自己会非常有效。如果你的目标是后者，那么这可能不是个好主意。在威廉与杰·范·贝维尔进行的一项研究中，他发现没有道德和情感语调的推文更能引发来自不同政治倾向的人之间的对话。在某种程度上，这在直觉上是说得通的。你上次因为别人对你大喊大叫而改变想法是什么时候？
And that leads to an interesting question. Why do we still see so much outrage, even when we know that it causes the people who disagree with us to tune us out? Aren't those precisely the people whose minds we want to change? Molly Crocket thinks there's a reason beyond our own personal motivations. It has to do with the business models of social media platforms and broadcast outlets. The goal of the platforms is not the explicit goal of keeping us outrage.
这就引出了一个有趣的问题。为什么我们仍然看到如此多的愤怒，即使我们知道这会导致那些不同意我们的人把我们屏蔽？难道这些人不正是我们想要改变其想法的人吗？莫莉·克罗克特认为，除了我们个人的动机之外，还有一个原因。这与社交媒体平台和广播媒体的商业模式有关。这些平台的明确目标并不是让我们保持愤怒。
It just happens to be that outrage is one way to grab attention and increase engagement. And their goal is engagement and holding our attention as much as possible because that's what's monetized in the business model of the social media platforms. The private benefits of outrage do not flow only to big companies. Increasingly, pundits, commentators and social media influencers use their visibility to drive advertising, book sales, and brand development. There is a new number one atop the New York Times bestseller list, Tucker Carlson,
碰巧的是，愤怒是吸引注意力和增加参与度的一种方式。他们的目标是参与度并尽可能多地抓住我们的注意力，因为这正是社交媒体平台商业模式中所变现的东西。愤怒带来的私人利益不仅流向了大公司。名嘴、评论员和社交媒体网红越来越多地利用他们的知名度来推动广告、图书销售和品牌发展。纽约时报畅销书排行榜上出现了一个新的第一名，塔克·卡尔森，
Ship of Fool, and seating Bob Woodward's fear, Trump and the White House. What motivated you to write this book? Well, you know, during the 2016 election, I was noticing the level of anger. Like my shirt, guys. Oh, yeah. Chelseayt.com. And if you haven't ordered it yet or haven't picked it up, make sure you do that. It's a great video.
《愚人船》，取代了鲍勃·是什么促使你写这本书？嗯，你知道的，在2016年大选期间，我注意到了愤怒的程度。喜欢我的衬衫吗，伙计们？哦，是的。Chelseayt.com。如果你还没订购或还没买，一定要去买一件。这是一段很棒的视频。
Because it's all about what makes it a bit more fun. These private incentives explain why the well-for-outrage runs deep. Why there are new things to be outraged about every hour of every day. While this makes excellent sense for the business models of influencers and their media platforms, Molly says it does not make much sense for the rest of us. It's just constant. There's a constant drip feed of outrage and it makes it hard to know where to focus your efforts. At a certain point, audiences start to become numb.
因为这完全关乎是什么让它变得更有趣。这些私人动因为何愤怒之源源远流长提供了解释。为什么每一天、每一小时都有新的事情让人感到愤怒。虽然这对网红及其媒体平台的商业模式来说非常合情合理，但莫莉说，对我们其余人来说，这并没有多大意义。这只是源源不断的。愤怒源源不断地倾泻而下，让人很难知道该把精力集中在哪里。在某个时刻，受众开始变得麻木。
If you were supposed to be angry about one thing on Monday and another on Tuesday, by Wednesday, you're exhausted. You may start to tune things out. You can't prioritize what to care about because the volume on every thing is turned to 11. In the process, things that actually need our attention, where the volume needs to be turned to 11, are drowned out. Careful vetting and investigative reporting today are regularly overshadowed by incendiary
如果你周一得为一件事生气，周二又得为另一件事生气，到了周三，你已经精疲力竭了。你可能会开始忽视这些事情。你无法排出优先次序去关心什么，因为每件事的音量都被开到了11档。在这个过程中，那些真正需要我们关注的、音量需要开到11档的事情，被淹没掉了。如今，严谨的审查和调查性报道经常被煽动性的
opinion. A similar dynamic is playing out in many parts of the world. In Britain, caught up in a bit of fight about whether to leave the European Union, about two-thirds of people say they no longer can tell the difference between rumor and reporting. If you're dialing up the volume on all outrage, then it may become more difficult to detect signal in an increasingly noisy public sphere. And this could increase errors that we make in deciding which issues we collectively think are most worthy of our attention and support.
观点所掩盖。类似的动态正在世界许多地方上演。在英国，深陷关于是否离开欧盟的争论中，大约三分之二的人表示他们再也分不清传言和报道的区别了。如果你把所有愤怒的音量都调大，那么在日益嘈杂的公共领域中，可能就更难探测到信号。这可能会增加我们在决定哪些议题最值得我们共同关注和支持时所犯的错误。
our attention and support. Mollie Crocket and William Brady are studying whether outrage might also be counterproductive to activists. Does blasting out angry tweets cause some people to feel they have done their part, to forgo the more difficult challenges of protesting in public, driving legislation, or showing up to vote? In other words, can outrage foster slakivism? I think that's a genuine worry. I don't think we have the data to know for sure, but it is a possibility and it is something we should worry about because if you're a certain type
我们的关注与支持。莫莉·克罗克特和威廉·布雷迪正在研究愤怒是否也可能对活动人士产生反作用。狂发愤怒的推文会不会导致一些人觉得他们已经尽了自己的一份力，从而放弃了上街抗议、推动立法或投票等更具挑战性的行动？换句话说，愤怒会不会助长懒惰式维权？我认为这是一个切实存在的担忧。我不认为我们有足够的数据来确切知道答案，但这是一种可能性，也是我们应该担忧的事情，因为如果你是某种特定类型
of person and maybe you only have enough time to take one action and not do both, then maybe expressing outrage because it is less costly on social media is what you end up doing. And then you don't actually go and you don't actually protest, you don't actually put pressure on legislators like what is really needed to create concrete change. For her part, Julie Zimmerman says her experience has changed the way she feeds off outrage. If you can limit yourself to just those occasional check-ins, a lot of the stories that are wasting people's time have gone away by the next time you sign on. She's also decided to refocus her emotional energy. You can stand up and be super outraged about something national, but if you really want to have an impact, yeah, go pick up litter in the intersection near your house or
的人，也许你只有足够的时间采取一种行动而无法两者兼顾，那么由于在社交媒体上表达愤怒的成本较低，你最终选择的可能就是它。然后你实际上并没有去行动，没有去抗议，也没有像真正实现具体变革所需要的那样去向立法者施压。就她而言，朱莉·齐默尔曼表示，她的经历改变了她靠汲取愤怒维生的方式。如果你能把自己限制在偶尔查看一下的程度，那么很多浪费人们时间的报道在你下次登录时就已经消失了。她还决定重新聚焦自己的情感能量。你可以站出来，对全国性的某件事感到无比愤怒，但如果你真的想产生影响，去捡捡你家附近十字路口的垃圾，或者
go, you know, work at an animal shelter. Like there are things that we can do every day that improve our lives and the lives of people around us, but they don't give us that you know, that drug of having a hot take, spread around social media. We tell ourselves, well, we're being good citizens, we're keeping up on the news, we're just entertaining ourselves, you know,
去，你知道的，在动物收容所工作。就像有些事情我们每天都可以做，它们能改善我们的生活和周围人的生活，但它们不会给我们那种快感——那种发表犀利言论并在社交媒体上广为传播的毒瘾。我们告诉自己，嗯，我们是好公民，我们在关注新闻，我们只是在娱乐自己，你知道的，
at great expense to our society. Getting angry at wrongdoers was helpful in our revolutionary past, but when people apply that same impulse today on talk radio and Twitter, what we get are doxing and death threats. Our capacity for outrage honed over millennia gives our society guardrails. It tells us how we are supposed to behave and it can lead to positive change. But use recklessly or for self promotion, outreach can poison the way we interact with each other. It can imprison us in our own echo chambers. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Path Shok. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Laura Corral, Thomas Liu and Jenny Schmidt, engineering support from Andy Huther. Our unsung hero this week is Will Chase, producing an episode about
代价却是以牺牲我们的社会为代价的。对做错事的人生气在我们过去的革命年代是有帮助的，但当人们今天在谈话类广播和推特上应用同样的冲动时，我们得到的是人肉搜索和死亡威胁。我们经过数千年磨练出的愤怒能力为我们的社会提供了护栏。它告诉我们应该如何行为，并能带来积极的变革。但如果被鲁莽使用或用于自我宣传，愤怒就会毒害我们彼此互动的方式。它会把我们囚禁在我们自己的回音室里。本期《隐藏的大脑》由帕思·肖克制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩剪辑。我们的团队包括劳拉·科拉尔、托马斯·刘和珍妮·施密特，工程支持来自安迪·胡瑟。我们本周的无名英雄是威尔·蔡斯，制作一期关于
outrage involved listening to lots of tape from cable news and talk radio. Will is a librarian here at NPR and we relied on his sleuthing to uncover some of the tape used in today's program. Thank you for your diligence, Will. If you liked this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. We're always looking for new people to enjoy hitting brain. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
愤怒的节目需要聆听大量来自有线新闻和谈话类广播的录音带。威尔是NPR的图书管理员，我们依靠他的搜寻能力来找到节目中用到的一些录音带。谢谢你的勤奋，威尔。如果你喜欢这一期节目，请务必与朋友分享。我们一直在寻找新听众来欣赏《隐藏的大脑》。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。